hi everyone
my name is mikhail legiben and i work at
wolfram research for
sound and vision group and today we are
going to
talk about handwritten text recognition
and analysis
what we have achieved and what basically
the main motivation was and we'll figure
out
what are the actual real life domains
that
utilize this type of uh functionality
and then i'll just leave um some time
and we could do
q on day or even after the talk uh if
there are
anything if there is anything you could
just reach me and we could
discuss that so i'll just
stop my video and get on the
presentation there
right so as i said uh we are going to
talk about
handwritten text recognition and the
analysis
and we'll see various techniques
architectures that are used to solve
this task
we'll also discuss what kind of domains
utilize this
problem and what kind of applications
are they around
and what is the actual situation
with the state of the art of the problem
the word and where we stand there
so just to give some background
the actual ocr task
well is pretty old
it comes from 1870s where people were
trying to solve problems
at the following problem so they wanted
to transfer the text from
one source to another source to allow
the blind people to read it
and this was around like 40 years long
project after which emmanuel goldberg
took this further
and converted the characters um
into telegraph code so the in the image
you could see
how the actual project looked like the
pipeline so basically it was
the character and the light source
coming on the character
and in the background frame there was
the original alphabet
and based on the outcome beam intensity
it was
identified which letter corresponds to
which
um which input corresponds to which
letter from the alphabet
and actually the this um pipeline
is the main reason why the technology
overall was called
optical character recognition and this
name is actually carried on
to nowadays as well
later when the computational power
started growing
um the technology moved into a new era
so-called image processing era
where people understood how could they
could analyze the images how they could
process do some classical
operations on images and this era was
pretty long
up to the point it moved to the next
stage
which is basically the deep learning
where we have neural networks and all
the ai engines to help us to solve the
task
and to gain actually real
high accuracies which were not really
achievable
with the classical image processing
approaches
along with the uh along with the
development of the
handwritten recognition another task was
growing simultaneously which was the
automatic handwritten text analysis
because non-automatic i mean by hand
people were doing it for a very long
time maybe for ages
but the the start of the automatic
analysis
uh varies around like 1980s
where there was already some
computational power not yet enough to
solve the task by that time
so they actually had to wait for the ai
technologies to come
and to help to solve the problem
nowadays the digital text appears in
a lot of places and it's so much that we
don't already
pay attention to it it's uh i mean
literally everywhere from
from from historical to medical domains
from criminal to mathematical
from the road camera attraction to just
mobile
phone pictures and the science corporate
recognition
i mean it's literally everywhere and
just to give you
an idea how important it is to handle
the
exactly handwritten analysis and
recognition
is the fact that every single day
like millions of petabytes of pdfs which
is like
crucially big number is being scanned
and
recognized so this is a real task this
is a real problem
that we see in various domains
so when we are talking about
a handwritten recognition we envision
the following so we have a
text that is written on a paper for
example here and then we need the
mechanism we need
ways to transfer this into something
that computer understands and can print
it out
in a more common font
so it's easy to understand the
following fact that what we have here is
a single input image
and we want to have the group of
characters which are like words lines
blogs and so on and so forth
so in in the other words if we try to
rephrase this statement
is like we have one input and we have a
lot of
outputs and each of outputs is a
character so
that's that's why the classical um
convolutional neural networks are not
good fit for this problem because they
are good for classification
like problems because of being so-called
one-to-one systems
right so another problem here is that
especially for handwritten text it's
nearly impossible to segment the
image accurately and to figure out which
part of the text or which part of a
letter
is contained in which uh segment
so we need something else here so
basically we need the
mechanism to have the handwritten text
to give it to some neural network and to
get the
already digital output
so one of the approaches to to
have this working is to go from one to
one system
to one to many system which is for
example the recurrent neural networks
so we what we have here is the
understanding of the
so basically we have um vector
of features a sequence of vectors of
features and we pass this to
our neural network which takes into
account the current state
uh and based on the current state and
based on the previous
processing output it basically produces
new
state and and and and new state and new
feature vector so if basically we try to
represent this
x here as input sequence y as an output
sequence
so if we just unfold this so what we
have here is
x is our the sequence of input
um sequence of inputs
edges are our states and f's are the
functions that process
both of them and produce new state so
there are various types of
uh rnn so-called cell architectures
and people were at the very beginning
very concentrated on vanilla rna cells
but then they realized that um
that that the linearity is actually a
trouble here so
that's why lstms and gru's
uh were introduced and they are in
active use
even today well not even today this is
the growing
technology actually uh there is of
course a disadvantage in this approach
which is basically the gpu
the gpu source is not really optimized
it is not really optimizable for this
type of tax
tasks and which makes the
parallelization
pretty impossible and hence
making the overall training process very
slow
another approach to to try to solve
this type of task is the usage of
transformers which was actually recently
introduced by facebook
and uh so the the one of the main
advantages over rnn that transformers
have is
the training speed and insurance and
we're not really going to go into
details uh about transformers during
this talk
because whatever solution we have is
purely based on rna plus cnn
architecture and we
get pretty good accuracies there we'll
talk about
them in a bit later so
uh all right so now that we know that we
need one too many systems let's
understand um another so
how the actual architecture would look
like the ideal
uh in the in this image we can see that
we have the input image and we use cnn
to extract the features
and then pass it to the
and then we need to segment the image
into the
pixel areas and which will then be
passed to our rnn and rnn will
basically process this sequence
decod pass it to decoder and the decoder
will eventually
give us the result and actually in the
trading process the only
difference here is that we need to
figure out what kind of loss function we
use for example here
we use uh we we showed the uh the loss
called ctc which was introduced by alex
grave so basically
these same processed
feature vectors are passed to ctc laws
and it's using the ground tools to
figure out how to
minimize it yet another approach to this
problem
is to use the cross
entropy laws and again this is more
moreover
like an fyi we're not going to
concentrate on this particular approach
um because um
the the loss like with with ctc like
losses we we can get
uh even better accuracies here so we'll
see
uh right before we we dive in into the
actual
laws there let's talk a bit about
the purpose of all of this so
recognizing the handwritten text is one
task but another task
is analyzing it
and what means to analyze the text is
basically
uh extract features that describe
the writing which will allow us to solve
tasks like
identification and verification style
analysis and
so on so forth so there are a lot of
real tasks like in medicine
in pseudosciences and all around that
really need these features to to be able
to
uh describe uh what's hidden in the
style of the writer so
[Music]
again here we have more than one
approach and the first
trivial approach that can come to the
mind is the
use of classification networks which is
basically
we could take a classification network
drop the last year
layers for the actual classification and
use the feature vector output as
our um the output as our feature vector
well this could theoretically work but
there is a huge disadvantage here
and that is basically the first thing is
whenever you want to retrain this for
new samples you have to do the
whole training from the scratch and this
is very computationally
expensive another disadvantage is that
the resulting representation
is just a linear combination of class
probabilities
which basically uh
is is a really big problem if if if the
number of classes is big i mean for a
small number of classes this can be
uh suitable solution but not for for
this type of
class where we have like a big very big
number of classes
another approach which is more
applicable here is so-called deep
metric learning so what is the point of
that so we have the loss
and it basically it knows the classes of
the images we have
and it forces the representations of
these classes
to be far from each other or close to
each other based on the similarities in
including space
so aside from from
many advantages over the classical
approach this approach gives us
ability to use the nearest neighbor
classifier on top of the representation
which is actually a very important
problem to solve the
scaling problem of course as every
everything in this world
even this approach has some disadvantage
disadvantages
and uh besides being slow there is a
good chance
for divergence uh a very
well mostly known example of a
diplo dip metric learning approach
is this so-called triplet a triplet loss
approach
so now knowing some background about uh
what
methodologies what what what
architectures are there
um let's talk about uh
maybe one of the most important things
in this tax task
which is the loss function definition
because this is
something that is going to
make your network have higher accuracies
one of the things so
again let's imagine we have writings
from different people so like this is
taken from so-called i am
data set and we have writings from
various people
so they write various texts and so on
so we need a good loss function to to
help
us to extract features in a way
so that we could do both identification
and verification at the same time
so as a first attempt we we took just
the classified
classical um the classification network
and
the the reason just was we needed some
you know like ground to start training
the
deep deep metric uh learning approach
not just not to do everything from
scratch to have some ground
as a pre-trained model um
and of course since the classification
network has its disadvantages we went
with
the first attempt was the most popular
triplet loss based training but
unfortunately as you can see in the
snippet below due to the large intra
class variability of the data
we got divergence and at this point we
had to rethink and figure out what we
can do to
fix the problem because the classical
well-known approach
didn't seem to work here so
and that made us to use something some
new
loss function which we call as
batacharia loss
layer but that's just but the charia
loss function
so that the reason it's called
batacharya is basically it uses the
distance formula for gaussian
distributions that pathetic
introduced and that's why the loss is
also named after him
so what the point of this laws
is basically to instead of is to
is to take into account it's to
calculate the intraclass
and inter-class distances of histograms
and
stimulate these gaussians to be as far
as possible so basically
the lower the the further they are the
less the intersection
is the better it is like for example in
the snippet below
you could see that here we have like
approximately the overlap is about six
percent which is
pretty good to use this as a feature
extractor for the
for the development so once again so the
loss function definition is one of the
most important parts here
all right so having some theory let's
see
how this uh thing come comes to life
so just to show very toy example
that everyone can reproduce let's just
pick some phones
for system from phones that i have on my
machine
they are more or less similar to
handwritings
we'll just use that font to generate
some images label them
and everything will look like this so we
will have the image and we will have the
ground truth for that
so we have this small data set here we
can just now split
between train data and test data and
we'll just use simple utilities to
create basically the architecture with
the laws and all the stuff
that we just talked about and so
basically we can see
we have the input as we saw it passes
to cnn retrieves the features
and then it passes to rnn the sequence
which basically then will pass it to the
decoder and give the output to us
so we could we could just train this
model
right out from there i'm training on cpu
just because i don't have gpu on
my machine even with with cpu this
training like
lasts about like five minutes for me we
are not
definitely not going to wait there so
i'll just stop this
and i will use the results that i have
i have prepared before so it's like four
and four and a half and it's on my cpu
and we can go ahead and jump into
testing it
so basically we can see that the result
is pretty reasonable pretty impressive
well in this particular case this is
actually perfect
but we might have some uh for example
like deluxe
it's like true or whatever but taking
into account that the data is like
was very very small and even with the
low data set we can get very reasonable
results so
just a toy example for you to understand
but now if we want to see
how this would behave with a bigger data
set with the proper training let's let's
see what we have here so let's just take
this uh snippet uh this will be the
image we will be
playing with so first of all
let's uh we need to find basically the
uh
where the text is located like so we use
fine image text which is actually not
designed for this type of purpose though
it
seems to be doing reasonable job here uh
we might actually use some lexicons
language models you know like to improve
the output result
so very very straightforward small
function
which will basically take the image run
it through the network give the output
apply the lexical model and the language
model if there is some
and we can just jump and test it
so we can see uh i'll just rerun this
all right so yeah there was some
initialization thing so
we can see that on my cpu like for that
image 0.7 seconds not bad
and we have the actually word by word
recognition happening here
we could also apply the lexicon which is
very trivial lexicon
that i used we see that the time jumps
up a bit but now we get some
alternatives to the recognition and
we could go even further and take any
language model to improve the
recognition based on this suggestion
from the lexical model or whatever
so if we look what is going on in the
world
in in the world uh in this uh on this
topic
uh so we if we take all possible
architectures around
uh we'll see that uh we are standing
right now
at some like fifth place or whatever we
can see that like
from second to fifth place the cluster
is very small and if we
go and pick the cnn plus rna
architectures only we are again
like fourth place so one of the uh
leaders here
is not using cnn plus rna and again the
second to fourth place is a small
cluster here
and uh just to see
so another sample that produced like uh
visually uh gives the idea what these
numbers
these accuracies these error rates mean
so
this is a text that i'm having trouble
to read some
um some parts of it but we we get pretty
reasonable
uh results on there and the good thing
is that we have
very strong vision how we can
improve this and go up to my i don't
know like our
our vision is to go up to two percent
the rate around or whatever but i mean
we have the distinct steps we know how
to improve
things that was on the recognition part
now on the
analysis part um so
let's let's uh let's face uh this kind
of problem which is
also known as forensic lands analysis so
we'll just take
writings from three people so whatever
i'm taking here writings from stephen
wolfram
albert einstein and marie curie so
so these are the writings we'll and now
we're just going to try to do something
with this
so before we try to uh let's um
so as i said so we thought this resonant
style
is the network that we trained and
created so this is basically going to
extract feature vector
from the input image and we and with
that feature vector we are going then to
be able to analyze
uh this looks something like this so you
have the image
and then from this image based on the
handwriting you have
a vector of numbers which is basically
the descriptors for your um for the for
the handwriting
so again like a few small utilities
for example we need the utility to patch
the image interfaces
and then we will try to solve the um
the problem here so this is the again
very simple function
and we will see for example we are
trying to see
if the third image which is this from
steven wolfram
match is the same with uh the third
image from albert einstein here
and we get falsies which is actually
what is expected
and then we can do the same thing with
two writings from the civil war film and
we will see that they
actually match though they pay attention
that the
text is pretty random it's not really
written in the same way it's not taken
from the same snippet
so so just to have an overall
just a bit bigger um
a bit bigger overview here we can see
that
in fact the results are very reasonable
even with the tiny data set that we've
taken
so we have very small dataset but even
with that here like two means basically
we correctly said that these two
writings are the same and here two means
that we correctly said that they are
not the same so we can see that we have
only a few failures here and again the
dataset is very tiny
but we can take this tiny data set even
further now
we can take you know like only three
snippets from
each of the people we had here and we
can just you know like
create um some test data there
and we'll just take three from here and
the rest will just take
for for testing and we can run
a very simple classifier which is pretty
fast here
and right so we we can see that
with this tiny data set we already got
around
like what 77 okay yeah last round it was
80 whatever
so yeah but you can see that there is
some epsilon here
so and and this is pretty good uh we can
actually see that
um interesting fact for example maria
curie and albert and stein
uh that there is a big number
a big number of failures here and if you
go and dig
into the problem you will see that
actually maria curies and albert
einstein's
handwritings are very similar to each
other and that was something
interesting we figured out when
preparing this example
uh so and
the final as as a as a kind of a final
conclusion to this example
so you could do the following you could
basically so
uh put in the writing and get the
identification of the writer
so this is basically just a combined
example for
both for verification and identification
last but not least um let's talk about
a bit different domain of the usage of
the of the technology
uh so this is basically about
signature validation uh verification and
identification so we have
uh random snippets of uh
[Music]
signatures and we'll just uh divide this
into again
training and testing pretty
straightforward here and
so let's look at the keys to understand
so we have
like numbers like oh oh zero zero one
and then we have zero zero one
underscore forge
so basically this zero zero one like
numbers represent
people who put their signatures there
and
number underscore forge means basically
someone tries to fake the signature and
now we're going to try to see if we
could identify
who is the writer for the signature
and if we could distinguish basically
verify if the
signature is valid or invalid so
again we'll just put the our training
data into the classifier
again pretty fast take into account my
i don't have any gpu here and and what
we get here okay so we get
like 93 percent which is reasonable well
the
data set is not that small here but
whatever
so this will give us to the
solution to the identification problem
so we will basically put an image and
then
it will tell who is the original author
basically
of the uh of the writing with 93 percent
of accuracy
now when we have this part we can go
further and try to adopt this to the
verification part
which is basically for example let's see
here so we have
um we have uh the following
uh structure here so we have pairs of
signatures
some pairs contain writings from the
same person
basically which is not forge and some uh
contain
one original and one forged sig
so we are again going to
split this between trend data and test
data and
see how our classifier behaves here
so there is some minor warm-up required
because
the classifier needs to pre-process
the output and whenever it
thinks it's ready it will give us the
result there
right so
yeah we we have like pretty big data set
here so
all right okay so it's going
and it's it's done all right so let's
see what we have here
[Music]
okay all right all right okay so we have
96.5 accuracy this is number of the
test examples it was run and
uh let's let's just see this in action
so basically we give it a pair
and it basically says if both of them
are valid like for example the first one
is the second one the forge of the
second one or or this is actually from
the original writer
and this is the country example here
when you have the
original writing and then you have the
forge and it says yes this is a forge
um and
so as i said we have what 96.5 here
so the state of the art of the problem
from 2017
was 4.63 and
we have 3.5 already with this network
which is
yet to come with a lot of more
improvements there
as i said before so that was actually
all i had
prepared for today i'm happy to take
some questions i know we went just a
little over time sorry for that
but i'm happy to take any questions now
or even afterwards if there are any
all right i don't think any anything
here and
if there is no anything else in
this zoom chat as well then i'm just
taking this there's no answers
so thank you for your attendance i'm
happy even to take questions
after the presentation just feel free to
reach me out
and ask anything you want to thank you